Speaker 1: All right, let's start today, I guess
we're calling this game. Do you buy it? We've
talked before about the people who have sort of
softly come out against Donald Trump, who were
previously associated with them. We've also talked
about the people who criticize him. But then when
when it really comes down to it, they go, I'd vote
for him again. Earlier this week, William Barr,
Trump's former attorney general, said the 2020
election stuff Trump was saying was B.S. he was
out of control, and he brought out a clown show of
lawyers. And then when Savannah Guthrie said, OK,
but if he's the nominee, are you voting for him
and he's like, Well, I'm not going to vote for a
Democrat. So that's horrifying and disgusting.
I have a different example for you today.
This is one of Donald Trump's former White House
press secretaries, Stephanie Grisham. My opinion?
Is that he she rather, when it comes to Trump, has
truly denounced him in a way where she's saying
she's out and here in this particular clip
on The View? Or no, not on the view, on some
other show. Maybe this is the view, she says.
He's a con man and I'm sorry and I don't want
people to vote for him. What do you guys think?
Speaker 2: But my point is now I messed up.
I am sorry. I will say that till the end of time.
But I want to give people an offering and I'm
going to do everything I can to educate people,
not talk down to them, educate people about who
he really is, that he is a con man, that it is
a cult like thing and that it's okay to just g